this has become the soundtrack of In
Time Of War
[Applause]
several missiles had the
russian-controlled Ukrainian town in
just one day
many people were injured among them too
in critical condition
I was here when the missile fell there
was an injured lady here we waited till
the ambulance came and took her
elsewhere in the town Ukrainian missiles
hit an Aid distribution center
six missiles fell here people were
gathering to take a to rebuild their
homes there were six injured here two of
them in critical condition
give a glimpse of how life is here
people are caught in the middle of a
bloody conflict that's changing their
lives and lives of the loved ones
forever
I've lived my life I want peace for my
children and grandchildren
icolovina was born in the region 70
years ago
she said
after home after an airstrike and now
she's on the verge of being displaced
for the second time
I live 20 kilometers from here my house
and my daughter's house were both hit
were always under shelling many people
were killed we want our lives back
what peace has become a scarce commodity
here